EU agricultural ministers have given
their backing for a coordination
facility to be set up to help develop
additional tools to control diseases in
niche crops such as fruit vegetables and
flowers the use of plant protection
products like herbicides on minor crops
is too small to be sustainable for
industry even though growers need them
and this leads to a shortage of such
products in the sector for this
coordinating facility will be funded by
a co-financing procedure by the
Commission to the tune of three hundred
and fifty thousand euros a year for the
next three years measured by another
250,000 euros each year by the Member
States and this will help to launch
projects but to coordinate experiences
and best practices and also form as you
said Minister a database on the issue
according to the European Commission the
direct impact of losses due to pests or
diseases from niche crops in the EU
totals more than 1 billion euros each
year the ministers also discussed food
waste in Europe and considered a
suggestion to exempt more products with
long shelf lives from the requirement to
have best before dates on their
packaging